We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. this
I think is going to be the final word on distractions
on the program.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, David Brent from Jersey city calling.
Uh, I just had a quick question for you.
You know, we've heard about the Bernie Sanders
distraction.
We know all about the producer Pat distraction
last week we were hit over the head with an
emergency appendectomy distraction.
Uh, my question is, are all these distractions
just a distraction?
Right.
Thanks.
You know, in a sense they are.
And I feel as though unfortunately we have
all become so distracted by identifying and
adjudicating varying degrees of distractions
that I want to put an end to this, the distraction
and let it be known right now.
There will be no more distractions including
the discussions of such distractions.
I am closing the book on it.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Uh, NATO's Stoltenberg is defending the NATO
stance on Turkey's offensive in Syria.
What is that stance and what are the implications?
We're gonna dig into that on today's bonus
show because by request there has been more
policy discussion requested for the bonus
show number two.
There is a one year old girl who has died
after being left in a car all day tragic,
horrible.
Uh, every time we hear about one of these
stories, this is the 50th hot car death in
2019.
Um, and I want to discuss what is behind this.
And there's actually a sort of macabre tie-in
that, Oh, I won't, I won't spoil it now, but
there's something I want to discuss on the
bonus show.
Related to that, we will also talk about incoming
or possibly already made endorsements of Bernie
Sanders candidacy in 2020 by Elon, Omar, Alexandria,
a Casia Cortez, and uh, maybe Rashida [inaudible].
We will talk about those endorsements and
endorsements more generally on the bonus show.
It is a jam packed bonus show.
Uh, I will also have news about the Vegas
conference of next week.
It's not the most exciting news unfortunately,
but maybe some people will like it.
Uh, and I will update you on the progress
of the membership drive that we have been
doing over the last five days, all of that
stuff, and much more on today's bonus show,
get instant access two ways.
Number one, become a member by signing up,
right.
Join packman.com number two, become a patron
by pledging@leastfivedollarsamonthatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
Speak to you then the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].